ce nouveau hans pinard ne fonctionne pas
du tout bon vent à tous et bienvenue
dans cette deuxième vidéo du calendrier
de l'avent on est pile poil à la moitié
comme tous les jours une vidéo à 6
heures du matin aujourd'hui je vous
présente un jeu je vous parle d'un jeu
que j'aime me particulièrement aussi et
comme par hasard c'est un jeu j'aime
beaucoup qui est de la même marque que
le jeu dont je vous ai parlé de 3
décembre dernier c'est à dire de chez
iello ça s'appelle time bomb
c'est une tueriie entre amis vous savez
gérer un jeu qui s'appelle menteur
menteur dont le lien aussi dans la
description d'ailleurs qu'un jeu de
bluff entre amis là aussi à beaucoup de
bluff et c'est pas du tout de même
principe mais il ya le même but de
chercher qui ment qui te cache quelque
chose
time bomb ça ressemble à ça et je vous
racontais l'histoire l'histoire c'est
que moriarty a mis une bombe dans big
ben et ses bombes a explosé un moment
donné il ya donc deux équipes xl1 on va
dire des méchants a mené par moriarty
qui veulent absolument que la bombe
explose et celle des gentils de sherlock
holmes sauf que tout le monde va se
faire passer pour un manque de liquide
de sherlock holmes pour désamorcer la
bombe est dedans ya les méchants mais
personne ne sait qui sont les méchants
même pas eu entre eux donc il faut
qu'ils puissent entre eux durant le jeu
déterminé aussi caler leurs collègues ou
pas pour faire exploser cette bombe pour
la désamorcer c'est très simple on a
tous des câbles vous la fais simplement
on a tous des câbles et à chaque tour on
va aller couper un câble chez quelqu'un
et cette personne va essayer de dire
attention pas moi j'ai des caps qui vont
faire péter la bombe attention moi j'ai
deux vocables à désamorcer etc
et c'est très vite le bordel c'est dès
le début une fois que les cartes sont
distribuées tout le monde commence par
dire moi je suis un gentil wam aussi moi
aussi moi aussi moi aussi ce qui ne
marche pas et c'est à vous de déterminer
par des questions c'est que du blabla
coin c'est du forcing c'est du bluff
pour réussir à faire exploser la bombe
ou pas ça se joue sur la forme d'un jeu
de cartes parmi lesquels on va trouver
des caps qui ne faut pas couper parce
qu'ils font exploser
bigben des câbles qui ne servent à rien
et des câbles qui désamorce la bombe
il y en a 80 ou à désamorcer au cours de
la partie l'équipe des méchantes et
rouge l'équipe des gentilles
ça c'est très classique hashtag pourquoi
toujours les rouges pour les méchants à
cause du communisme à mon ami et ça se
jouera à partir de quatre joueurs à
quatre joueurs c'est possible alors dans
le challenge
il ya quelque chose qu'il faut faire
quand vous jouez à quatre joueurs c'est
quand vous allez distribuer les rôles de
qui est gentil qui est méchant
vous préparez 3 gentils et de méchants
vous mélangez vous distribuez ça aux
quatre joueurs et donc à une carcasse de
côté ça pimente un peu le jeu comme ça
on ne sait pas s'il ya un ou deux
méchants dans la partie mais le format
idéal celui sur lequel on rit le plus je
trouve ces cinq joueurs et six joueurs
comme d'habitude vous mets le lien de ça
dans la description dans lesquelles vous
retrouvera aussi d'autres idées cadeaux
comme comme mon livre si ça vous tente
les places pour l'olympia des arts
formation aux diverses aussi diverses
que même peut-être variés n'hésitez pas
à liker la vidéo si c'est pas encore
fait à vous abonner si c'est pas encore
fait non plus peut-être à me parler de
vos parties de time bomb si vous
connaissiez déjà le jeu c'est c'est
vraiment un très très bon jeu entre
poteau et rendez vous demain à 6 heures
shao
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]